[Music]
good to talk to you Ian uh you've uh had
many celebrated roles in in your life uh
initially as a uh English literature
academic then as a psychiatrist
researcher in Neuroscience more recently
you're best known for your books and and
as a philosopher really and I wondered
which of these uh very different roles
is closest to your heart and which has
given you most
satisfaction
so of course philosophy never has an
ultimate answer but it doesn't make the
the the quest pointless and I've enjoyed
it
enormously what I've been able to do I
think is to bring a philosophical mind
to bear on
Neuroscience in a way which I hope is
productive and
creative but um yes I I got into the
literary Studies by accident actually
what happened was that um I wanted to go
to Oxford and you had to sit and examine
a school subject but philosophy wasn't
one of them so um I sat it in English
and I went for um interview and they
said what you want to read and I said
philosophy and theology partly because
um PPE which as you know is philosophy
politics and economics didn't
particularly grab me because that's the
aspect of philosophy I'm not really
interested in whereas a kind of
philosophy at least has room for
theology in it and a kind of theology
that has an interest in philosophy
seemed perfect but it wasn't an honors
degree and so my my interviewer said you
can't do a non-honors degree you've got
to come and do an honors degree so why
don't you just do English you're clearly
kind of interested in and okay at it so
I ended up doing that right that's all
very fasc I me I did PP myself then
became a philosopher so you know you
interesting that that parall so I was
going to ask you but I think in a way
you've answered that the question is
whether you're the neuroscience and uh
your researches there the science had
led to your philosophy or whether
philosophy has led to the science or
influence but I think you've answered
that and say actually it was your
philosophical approach which has driven
your Neuroscience work you're right in
that in my 20s I wrote a a sort of
philosophical book about the way in
which we approach works of art called
against
criticism and um what I felt I was
trying to explain was something to do
with the Mind Body problem that we took
these embodied beings works of art and
turned them into disembodied
abstractions and that this was running
in the opposite direction to the way the
work of art itself LED you and in doing
so they lost all their implicit meaning
and they lost their uniqueness and it
all became explicit and dull like
explaining a joke so I thought there's
something wrong here and uh you know for
all all the Mind Body philosophy
seminars I went to nobody really
approached the thing in a properly
embodied way and I thought the only way
to do this is to become a doctor and
actually see what happens to real people
when something goes wrong with their
brain and it affects that whole sense of
being or something happens in their
psychological world and it affects their
body and that that's what I did so I I
became a
doctor and you obviously in your in your
you've had two major major works
uh your first master in his oser put
forwards a completely new account of the
brain yes and more recently matter of
things of course uh explores the nature
of reality Consciousness and the Divine
yes and
um I wonder whether in the light
especially of what you have just said
whether you really see yourself as a
religious
thinker a difficult one in an apathetic
way I would say I don't see myself as a
non-religious
thinker in other words I don't I'm not
one of these people who has no time for
no interest in and no room for whatever
it is that people
have timelessly explored which is the
sense of something that goes beyond the
immediate and the the rationally
explicable and
um so I I'm it's interesting because a
lot of philosophical colleagues said
don't don't include a chapter on the
sacred in your book cuz everyone will go
oh no he's a faith head you don't listen
to him um and I've been waiting for
Flack from atheistic people I haven't
got any at all the only flak I've got
has been from rather down the the middle
Christians who've written to me saying
there's a sort of Christ shaped hole in
your account why do you not talk about
it and there are two reasons for that
one is that I wanted to be inclusive not
exclusive I wanted anyone who had any
inkings of anything Divine or sacred to
be able to be welcomed in and not have
this thing we're Christians here so you
better sign up to eight impossible
things before breakfast um and and the
other thing really is that um I I I I
don't really myself feel entirely
certain what I think about Christianity
what I can say is that it seems to me to
have quite possibly the
most um Rich Mythos about the nature of
relationship between humans and the
sacred that there is um whether I
believe certain things are literally the
case seems to me almost irrelevant
that's interesting so I think that maybe
good leads on to something I'd like to
ask you about which is is uh your
understanding of truth I think it's
probably fair to say that you and I
share a um criticism of reductionism and
uh so forth and materialism in science
but we both see how important science is
and see that you has to pursue it but
maybe there's an area where we have a
rather different approach which would be
in that I think that while you are often
wishing to point to the our inability to
actually access truth I feel quite a lot
of the time you're wanting to say there
is a truth and that we should try and
and get to it is that fair absolutely
fair and I think there's a distinction
to be made between something that's just
out there and we need to go fast as we
can and get it and something that is
always going to be a matter of greater
or lesser approximation so I don't hold
that there is a truth that somebody one
day will hold and say this is the truth
but I believe that we should be and are
compelled drawn by our our minds our
imagination our intellect towards um
what wondering which of these various
things that people believe is trer than
the
others and do you think then there's any
tension between on the one hand pointing
in a way to our inability to access
truth and at the same time trying to be
telling people uh what you think think
the truth is or is is there some sort of
tension in that well there would be if I
thought that I was telling people what
the absolute truth is but I think I'd
like to distinguish between
certain areas of life so for example in
science um I believe that there are
certain
findings let's take it no further than
that there are findings that are very
hard to contest in other
words a review of an enormous number of
subjects seems to show that this is
truer than that and and that's fine um
and and that's the kind of truth that in
part one of my new book the matter with
things which is devoted to neurology and
and and
neuropsychology is is to show that
certain things about the brain are
assertable up to a point I mean science
is always an approximate thing um one
way of looking at science is it's the
Perpetual history of mistakes and
beliefs because of course they're always
replaced in time but it's nonetheless
there is grounds for saying that when
you come to you know what is the nature
of the cosmos and and so on on we're in
an area where certainties are fewer and
and empirical tests are rarer so what
we're really talking about is a way of
looking at the world at the cosmos at a
human life that makes more sense than
any of the other
Alternatives so it's interesting where
you put it makes more sense um avoiding
somehow saying that it's uncovered what
is the case no I think it has uncovered
but it's that this is always a process
that one that has never completed so
it's perfectly respectable to be a
Seeker after truth I think it's rather
disreputable to say I have found the
truth and and of course the fact that we
can't be certain doesn't mean that
everything's up for grabs and that um in
a postmodern way anything that you want
to say is true I don't believe that I I
think that's I was going to call my new
book um the not the matter with things
but there are no things and somebody
pointed out to me that might align me
with a certain postmodern school which
basically says that whatever it is that
we think is something we just make up
ourselves I don't believe that I also
don't believe in a kind of naive realism
that there's just stuff out there in
some way that a lot of scientists seem
to believe and it's just our job like GE
couns photographic plates or whatever to
pick up the data and one of the puzzles
there isn't it is that if if you don't
buy the naive realism story about the
world you are in this sort of
interregnum type space of wanting to say
things but at the same time having a
caveat that this shouldn't be taken as
definitive in in some way and do you
think that W when is doing that saying
uh you know take it like this but this
isn't definitive that that that itself
is a is like a a new form of
definitiveness that you're say well this
is how it really is um that we can't we
can't really grasp the ultimate and
we're just in this in this space of
trying to point to something do do you
think do you think there is a puzzle
there or not I don't think it's a puzzle
in that there's no alternative to it I
think that as a philosopher um you're
not going to say but I don't really
believe this because in that case why
did you just bore us with saying it why
don't you say what you do believe so we
all say what we believe to be the case
but belief is inherently approximate we
are fallible beings
our experience is not Universal but is
that claim belief is inherently
approximate that sounds like a
definitive account the belief is
inherently proximate well I there is a
word game like this which goes um the
only thing that's um certain is that
those who believe that there's anything
certain or wrong and and that that would
be the succinct way of putting what
you're pointing to and to an extent that
there are paradoxes like this is untrue
um you you um you have to accept that
but I think that you and I probably know
that there's a quite a difference
between a certain kind of dogmatic kind
of philosophy in which one thinks simply
this is you know advancing the sum of
whatever it is we know in a in a
reliable and way that is never going to
be revised or repeated and a view that
whatever it is that we understand is to
some extent provisional but that we
don't have the choice in this life to be
completely certain we only have the
choice to do what seems to us
better so in your in your account of the
brain you have the the uh essentially a
notion of two uh different ways of
attention left brain attention right
brain attention do you see your own
Theory as a product of your left and
right brain I certainly do um and I
don't think that I'd be better off or
anyone would be better off if they had a
left hemisphere ectomy um it has its
role my only problem is that it tends
because it knows literally less than the
right hemisphere that it thinks it knows
everything and um that's dangerous
because it rules out a whole other way
of seeing the world or understanding the
world which is more subtle harder to
articulate but I think more important
and foundational so I I I'm I'm quite
happy to make judgments and say this is
better than that but that just doesn't
entail me in being somehow mistaken
because I've I've made a certainty out
of anything I don't
think and do you think therefore the
risks that you point to in the way that
left brain goes about things do you
think that you are at the same risk you
know is there are we all at
risk left brain and and how do you deal
with that internally for yourself you
know is there a bit of you it's bit of
that says actually I need to be a bit
careful about that left brain stuff no
no no that's not how it works as I
imagine you you you would believe
anyway no what it is is
that I suppose over a lifetime of
pondering on on many philosophical
questions I've seen that there are
discrepancies between different points
of view and people have said well this
school thought thought this and this
school thought that and you take your
pick um but I've always felt that um
there were unarticulated truths but were
un articulated partly because they're
very difficult to put into language but
are nonetheless important for that and
so I I learned early on to be attentive
to implicit meaning to um the idea that
there weren't these hard and fast
certainties and in doing that I think my
or maybe I I don't like to put a chain
of causation here in something which is
probably circular in nature um that that
something arose in me which was a point
of view towards the world which was that
of the right Hemisphere and it's not
that I disrespect the left hemisphere I
only disrespect it when it comes to me
and claims that it's the master and
knows everything because it doesn't so
um you were just saying uh in that that
um you didn't see yourself as needing a
a left brain ectomy as it were and uh I
I guess the the reason why you felt you
want to say that is because it is of
course the case that um sometimes you
give the impression that you know the
left brain is the baddy you know that we
need to be guard against this left brain
and somehow the right brain is is it's
got everything good on its side yes and
do you do do you think that's how it is
I mean do should we be suspicious of the
right brain as well as it were is is is
there something about the right brain
that makes it actually less threatening
than the left brain it it it behoves us
to be skeptical always but not skeptical
to the point of paralysis we should be
skeptical of our own skepticism as well
but um effectively yes the left brain is
not in any sense a baddy until it's and
this is the crucial point until it
decides that it knows it all and it can
run the show and it's so deficient in
knowledge compared with the right
hemisphere I mean sound bite I often use
but can easily defend and have done at
Great length is that the left hemisphere
helps us apprehend the world I.E grasp
onto the world and get it but the right
hemisphere helps us comprehend the world
which means holding it together and that
is a quite different faculty and in part
one of the matter with things which is
the neuros psychology I work through
nine possible or eight possible portals
for
knowledge information of the world come
in and I show that in all but one of
these the right hemisphere is
demonstrably more reliable um and so in
that sense we need to be more worried
about what the left hemisphere is
telling us because without the
contribution of the right hemisphere it
becomes frankly delusional I'm not using
that in some loose metaphorical way it
actually does become prey to delusions
hallucinations and things that we would
all accept are unreal and I'm not the
only person to have pointed this out by
any manner of means so to that extent it
behoves us to be more suspicious of what
we can see comes from the left
hemisphere's attempt to to tackle
something than the right but as I said
at the outset it behaves us always to be
skeptical indeed well look uh you know
uh it's been a pleasure talking to you
Delight having you here thank you very
much it's been lovely being here and
talking to you for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to The
Institute of Art and ideas at II
TV